you know each new writing night we'd  give a brief to the writers which would  challenge one thing in the audience like  make an audience fall in love with the  character make an audience forgive a  character of a heinous crime or like  find something that makes an audience  laugh and then makes an audience feel  sick for a laughing and we used to do  these monthly and I learned so much  there about how to surprise your  audience because as an audience myself I  just I never want to be surprised in a  truthful way not in a kind of like  but I wanna  I wouldn't be as surprised as much as  people surprise me you know people  surprise each other all the time and